[Music]
lucas is in phoenix
hey lucas what's up
nothing much dave how are you doing
better than i deserve how can i help
so i am 19 years old i just graduated
high school probably about two months
ago i have no debt
i've been working a life guarding job
here in arizona for about roughly four
years so i'm on good terms with them
however it doesn't pay a lot so i've
been incorporating my new landscaping
business and then that's been really
taken off um so
the issue is with all of this is i've
been recently kicked out of the home and
it's not been for you know not going to
college or being lazy or alcoholic drugs
or anything like that um you just really
you don't really see eye to eye and we
saw we tried going to like you know
therapy and whatnot to try to work
through that but this really hasn't been
working out so my mom wanted me out and
i've been staying with a friend of mine
who goes to my same church and so we've
been you know he's been mentoring me and
kind of teaching me some stuff about
finances and whatnot just trying to help
me get my feet up underneath me um and
so my whole goal here is to try to do a
minimal a minimalistic mindset um just
so that way i can focus into more of my
future not my like the present and you
know wasting money on certain things and
so right now i have no credit history um
and so it's very difficult to
you know buy anything that's going to
help me live somewhere right so um
currently i'm with him and so i'm
thinking of um getting like a mini
camper that i can pull on the back of my
truck and i have an actual place to park
it um and it's about
17 000 um outright so if i walk out the
door it's about 17 000 to buy that i
don't want to lease it very you know
because
they go down in value so quickly and
it's really just a bad deal that way so
i really don't know what to do because
all i have right now is about thirty
seven to four thousand dollars
that's kind of a scary place lucas
yeah yeah it's it really uh it is and um
yeah it kind of woke me up a little bit
yeah
so um
you have a landscaping business
and you are making what kind of income
so um when i'm just kind of using it as
a side gig which was um you know a
couple years ago it was making in you
know 100 bucks here 300 there
what do you make you need money right
now what are you making right now
correct
right now um like for the past week or
so i've probably brought in about
two thousand dollars
within a week and a half two weeks doing
what
uh just landscaping
okay
all right and so you're out there
hustling up landscaping business right
oh yeah i'm out there every single day
um and then in my land my you know my
lifeguarding
that um if i was to work close to 40
hours a week i'm making about 1407 after
taxes every two weeks the paycheck
that's bringing me down about 813 to 800
bucks which is nothing so
yeah the landscaping is going to make
you a lot more
um
if you can get that business
on top of that what
oh i'm just i'm working for myself so
it's more meaningful it has greater
potential that type of stuff right this
second i don't give a crap about that
i'm just trying to get you where you
have shelter and food
yeah your your life's meaning is way
down my list right now for you i just
want you to have a place to live and
food
and
stability sustainability then we can
worry about meaning and
self-actualization and
um those kinds of things but right now
i've got a 19 year old homeless kid
um
on the phone and that that's what's
running through my head so
um
no you do not need to buy a 17 000
camper under any circumstances
okay okay not a good move you have four
thousand dollars if you can find a ratio
used one for a thousand bucks which you
probably actually can
and you want to live in that for
uh four months
while you
build up some more cash and stabilize
your income and then go rent an
apartment with a roommate
that's okay
if you can can you how long can you live
with the guy you're with
uh she said i mean as long as it takes
as long as i'm working my app you know
pardon me working on my butt off to get
myself stabilized and i do have a very
good work ethic like i'm out here
working a ton i'm not i'm not
questioning that okay so right um
so we need to define that because when
someone comes to stay in my home i want
to know when they're leaving
right
yes and i don't want to stay there
because i know i know but i just as long
as it takes could be until you're 29 he
didn't mean that so i want to know what
he meant he's thinking i'm so what he's
meaning is like six months okay you know
max let's just do this
listen you know let's just do that let's
just stay there for a while
okay
and and so
listen listen and build up how big a
pile of cash
can you build up
during that time and get your income
stabilized and then get a roommate right
yeah i mean it sounds like you have very
little expenses right now lucas so i
want you to take advantage of that while
this this man has given you a lot of
grace uh and like dave saying i would
not go into debt for this camper i know
you want to live this minimalist life
and i respect that that's not minimalist
but 17 000 camper when you're broke is
not minimalist yeah
you i think you should need to rent and
get a roommate if that after that six
months you don't have enough for that
camper but that camper is not going up
in value and it's a depreciating asset
so it's basically like you saying hey
can i take out a loan for 17 000 to get
a truck and we're gonna say no
so
i want you to to live your dreams you're
19. you've got a lot of life ahead of
you but right now you need a solid
foundation you don't have that and so
you've got a great work ethic like
you're talking about use that to your
advantage and use this free rent to your
advantage and sock away maybe you could
save up five ten grand go rent somewhere
for another six months and maybe a year
two from now you get that camper here's
my prediction okay
listen just listening to you if you'll
stay on the track and probably going to
lose the lifeguard job for more hours on
the landscaping if you can get more and
more and more landscaping business
you're going to stabilize your income in
the next four months at three to four
thousand dollars a month
and you're gonna have about ten thousand
dollars in the bank four months from now
with that situation you can go rent an
apartment
and get a roommate or rent a room from
somebody
uh very inexpensively and then take your
next step
which is continue to continue to grow
your business and start thinking about
your careers but paying cash all the way
this camper
it sounds kind of romantic and like
you're again you're being sacrificial or
something but it's really going to end
up being a long-term bad play
and uh so i'm going to talk you out of
that one
yeah it's a tough lifestyle i know it
sounds fun i mean you're 19 you could
probably swing it for a year or two but
eventually you just want a real place to
go and sleep so
yeah and just you know here's the thing
if you can get your home
situation sustainable and stabilized
then you can start working on your
career and you can start looking out and
thinking about your future and you can
start thinking about you know investing
and upgrading and
whatever you know taking some classes or
doing whatever it is you want to do with
your life there's a lot of things you
can do from there but for right now
let's get
the food shelter clothing transportation
and utilities going and get those basic
things underway and that's what i'd tell
you to do first
and um along the way
um
even if you're not living there
stay in touch with your mom
your dad
tell them what's going on
um not i don't know what all has
happened here i can't tell
um but that's not what this calls about
but it is what it's about that's what
puts you here
so i i want you to continue to work on
that relationship if there's any way
possible
obviously if you can't you can't but um
you you want to have tried everything
you do not want to live in regret on
that
and so
um
you know maybe you and your mom can be
friends when you don't live there
maybe that takes the stress off of it i
don't know how all that works in your
world but um
just make sure you just let them know
you're okay and that you're working
and um
that you care about them and so on just
continue to that connection i think
that'll be very valuable for you
ten years from now especially um maybe
not 10 minutes from now but 10 years
from now
wow yeah i mean he just got punched in
the face a little bit and he's 19. he's
having to grow up fast but i think if he
can build his foundation for a little
while and get back on his feet he's
going to be just fine